so I want to talk about free speech
because free speech seems like it is
constantly under attack generally in the
world but more in America now that's
where I'm going to focus right this
second and there's a bunch of things
that have been happening lately
attacking free speech which as a guy
that talks for a living it is pretty
much the most important thing that there
is in my opinion so I want to talk about
two things first I was start with this
bill maher sam Harris Ben Affleck
kerfuffle that happened on real time a
couple weeks ago where Ben Affleck
called Bill Maher and sam Harris racist
basically while they were discussing
Islamophobia and then everyone started
attacking everybody there were articles
written B's bilimora racist berkeley
university here in california bill maher
was supposed to be the commencement
speaker now they have a change.org
petition to stop him it has over 2,000
signatures already so bill maher who was
the standard bearer for the liberal
cause who is relentlessly attacked all
religions equally who stands up for
liberal principles like women's rights
and gay rights and things of that nature
uh suddenly he's not liberal enough for
Berkeley University and they want us
they don't want to listen to him now I
know that the free speech of course in
the Constitution in the Bill of Rights
it protected free speech from the
government but I think we can do a
little bit better than that this isn't
about the government this is about these
college kids that don't want to listen
and then the other one was Carol
Costello on CNN you know she played that
tape of bristol palin calling the cops
after the the assault and carol was
basically laughing it was actually
pretty gross what carol costello on CNN
was doing but then suddenly people all
the right attacking carol costello and
she should be fired and see it as you
get right over and I think we've become
incredibly intolerant of hearing you
know it we have free speech but you
don't have the freedom to not be
offended we're supposed to be offended
and you're supposed to hear things that
upset you and maybe that'll make you
double down on what you believe so I
think we can all do a little bit better
recognizing that not everything is
catered to exactly what you think and
what you believe that hearing different
things even when they're stupid I mean
just flat out stupid with the carol
costello thing especially and whether
you think bill maher's a bigger they're
not trying to get him fired I mean come
on everyone needs to just calm down take
it down a notch
and speak off their mind we don't want
everyone to become afraid of speaking
because then that's where the bad stuff
kicks in and we're not about that are we